faire le plein de son camion un acte de
routine pour ce chauffeur
mais depuis quelques temps sa pratique a
changé maintenant il ne verrouille plus
de bouchons on laisse aux verts 1
ça évite les les coups de pioche dans le
bas du réservoir et puis et puis c'est
aussi bien qu observer au moins ça m est
d'avoir un manque à gagner le cas mais
on peut rouler comme le lendemain il y a
deux ans l'entreprise a été victime
d'actes de siphonnage jusqu'à 2000
litres par semaine
les voleurs ont finalement été
interpellés les iran penser ensuite être
tranquille mais la hausse du prix des
carburants semble à nouveau aiguiser
l'appétit des délinquants on a également
une décharge sur la commune de lux ou et
bien en permanence au minimum un engin
ou depuis un ou deux mois environ la des
vols de carburant que ce soit le
week-end en bourgogne
pas d'augmentation significative des
vols ces derniers mois même si des cas
sous déclarer régulièrement les
professionnels du transport sont tout de
même inquiet et face à ces délits ils se
sentent impuissants
il n'y a pas une solution il ya les
méthodes de prévention effectivement
mais c'est à dire c'est difficile
d'endiguer un phénomène qui aujourd'hui
est vraiment très courant sur l'ensemble
du territoire et la convoitise des
voleurs pour les réservoirs ne risque
pas de diminuer le gouvernement a
annoncé une hausse des taxes sur les
carburants
ces prochains mois